now to breaking news overnight from
Washington long time Senate Republican
leader Mitch McConnell is in the
hospital today his condition is unknown
Nicole Killian on Capitol Hill is
following this story Nicole good morning
to you what happened here
well good morning to you Gail a leader
Mitch McConnell was taken to a D.C
hospital last night after suffering from
a fall a spokesperson tells CBS News he
tripped at a local hotel during a
private dinner he has been admitted to
the hospital where he is receiving
treatment it remains unclear what his
injuries are at this point or how severe
this is not the first time the 81 year
old Senator has been hospitalized after
a serious fall back in 2019 McConnell
took a spill at his Louisville home he
suffered a fractured shoulder that
required weeks of recovery and physical
therapy he had a triple heart bypass
surgery back in 2003 he's also a
childhood polio Survivor McConnell is
one of several Senators who have been
hospitalized in recent weeks including
Senators Feinstein betterman and Casey
McConnell is in his seventh term and
this year he became the longest serving
party leader in Senate history
Roy Nicole is the senator McConnell's
been through a lot we certainly wish him
a speedy recovery for him we're also
learning about this there's a major data
breach we're hearing in Washington that
allegedly is impacting members of
Congress that senators and members of
the House of Representatives have been
told that their personal information was
potentially exposed after their Health
Care system was targeted what can you
tell us about that anything
well that's right you know Congressional
leaders are demanding answers about this
hack a notice was sent to lawmakers from
the chief administrative officer which
said the Cyber attack occurred on a
health insurance portal called DC Health
Link the officials said account
information for hundreds of House and
Senate staff were stolen according to
the FBI speaker Kevin McCarthy and
minority leader Hakeem Jeffrey say the
FBI told them that the information was
purchased on the dark web and may
include names of Family Social Security
numbers and home addresses an
investigation is now underway Gail okay
hope they figure that out thank you
Nicole